bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you I may be your host
you're watching the Deen show and we're
here helping you understand the purpose
of life why you've been created while
you're here where you're going when you
die these very important questions that
many people are forgetting to ask
they're not reflecting about they're not
thinking about my next guest like
majority of my guests they came on the
light bulb went on they figured out you
know what money is not buying me
happiness fame is not buying me
happiness it's not attaining helping me
attain what really my soul needs and
that's something beyond the material
things
my next guest was a club hopper and
beyond he was a club owner and from
Friday to Friday he was living making
money spending money and he was not
happy at all
and then he went from there he tried to
fill that void not only with xanax and
all the other things that people start
to take when the depression kicks in but
he was dealing with the the magician's
people who now you go to and you're just
like hey I'm sick you know of course
you're sick you feel depressed this I of
course you feel depressed inside because
you're missing the most important thing
the connection with the crater he was
missing that so then he went to
magicians and he went to sue sayers and
you know trying to get a prescription to
feel better but doctors couldn't give it
to him nor could the magician's but it
had to come from the one who created
this whole universe and everything in it
so he's here to share his story with us
he was father was also a Hindu priests
man this guy's story is incredible it's
amazing you don't want to go nowhere
don't miss this we'll be right back with
his story here in the V show this is the
Dean
you know this is the thesis but angel
this is the absalom alaykum peace be
with you we're back here in the Deen
show with our special guests here our
brother your brother all the way from
New York how are you brother
Salaam alaikum peace be with you
walaikum s-salam wa rahmatullah maybe
some bets of Allah be upon you thank you
for being for us how are you doing
brother I'm good I'm to LA now this is
very exciting because you're actually I
believe the first Hindu guests that we
have former Hindu guests that we have on
the Deen show so the viewers are excited
to know your story on how you went from
being a Hindu and how you came to the
way of life of all the messages have got
Islam complete submission and surrender
to the one who created creation but not
to the creation worshipping only God
that's Islam how did you come to Islam
talk to us yeah I used to be a Hindu I
come from a strong Hindu family my
father was actually a Hindu priest and
we came from a following Hindu a Hindu
background and you know my journey to
Islam is a little long and interesting
story but in short you know when I came
to to Islam is is through a business
that I had and that business that I had
was actually a nightclub and through
that nightclub you know I came to a
point where I was going to a lot of
problems in this nightclub and you know
in the in a Hindu family the first thing
that they do as you know when someone's
having an issue is that they bring you
to the Hindu priests which is a pundit
and this Hindu priests you know the
first thing he would tell me to do is
you know stuff evolving black magic so I
got involved with this black magic for a
year to try to better my life because
this is something that he told me was a
part of the religion and in doing so
things still kept going in the downward
spiral and I kind of got a little fed up
and I kind of got frustrated and said
you know how can they be a god if I'm
praying everyday to God
and making suited to God in the idle
form and all these different idols and
all these bad things are happening to me
so one day I had a friend who was
actually looking into Islam and he
mentioned to me he said why don't you
check out Islam and I said you know why
am I gonna check out this terrorist
religion and you know we're all ignorant
at the time so I went to get a Quran and
you know as a new Muslim you know a new
person looking to the Koran you're not
too sure what to expect and looking into
English Quran it's a little confusing
but the first ayah that I came across
looking at the Quran was ayah from surah
17 inma 8 that said it may be that your
Lord may have mercy on to you but if you
revert to your sins we shall revert to
our punishments and it really hit me
because that I spoke to me directly it
was directly talking to me and I got
really interested and I started looking
more into religion but the religion the
decor and explained everything that I
was going through my life and explained
in detail everything my black magic
explained in detail all the problems
that explained in detail about the
people who worship the idols so when I
saw these things I still wanted to dig
deeper into Hinduism but I noticed that
Hinduism said you should worship one God
and it says that him that God has has no
shape or no form and when I saw these
things you know I said you know I'm
gonna look more into Islam and what I
did I decided to take my Shahada
hamdullah tell us now what are some of
these what are some of the Hindu beliefs
what Hindus believe um the Hindu belief
Hindus they really follow tradition they
don't really follow any specific
specific book because if they did their
actual text the Veda is the Bhagwad Gita
Upanishad the Puranas all these
different texts says to worship one God
that he is one supreme being without a
shape without without a image or without
a parents or offspring but the Hindus
they actually worship many gods they
believed that God manifested in
different forms so they worship an
individual God based on what they need
such as if they need wealth they'll
worship one God for that if they need
power or or they going through hard
times they worship another god for that
for death they worship another god for
that but in
Hindu scriptures it says that they
should only be one God should be
worshiped and the Hindus instead of
following the scripture they actually
follow their tradition so the in in
following the tradition they in turn
worship and multiple gods and multiple
statues and multiple images of something
representing what their their idea of a
God would be now that you found this
snack tell us does it make sense is it
clear is everything in Salaam lucid what
Islam now everything makes sense with
Hinduism I was always confused I always
wondered why couldn't I just talk to God
and say God you know just help me out
just give me give me give me something
down here
but with Islam everything makes sense
now I mean I have in detail an
explanation for whatever question that I
may have I have in detail what's gonna
happen to me after I die I have in
detail what the purpose of life is I
have in detail of what why the trees
grow why everything happens you know the
difference is night and day now that
you've left the nightclub scene you've
left that life of debauchery following
your lusts and desires are you truly
happy yes at the nightclub it's it's
something that that a lot of people want
they want the wealth they want the
attention and people in the nightclub
it's a fantasy that they're living there
they're basically trying to live out a
movie scene they're basically trying to
just indulge in every fantasy that they
have and I personally think you know the
lifestyle that I had then and life that
I have now yes I may not have the wolf
that I have then but this Dean that I
have this religion this faith this this
knowledge that I have now nothing in the
world can buy that back no money in the
world can amount to that I had money
then when I had the night cup I had fame
I had I had wealth I had everything I
ever wanted in the nightclub but I
wasn't happy there was a void there was
a void that it was longing to be filled
and with Islam Islam came and filled
that void and there's no money in the
world that can buy that back from me now
tell us before you came to the
realization that Islam was the truth and
we know it's based on proof and
evidences for anyone who takes a sincere
humble approach an analytical approach
they'll come to the same realization
that you have that Islam is indeed not a
man-made
but it is from the crater that was an
earth before you became a Muslim before
you started practicing Islam did you
look into some of the other man-made
religions yes I did look into other
religions I wanted to disprove Islam
before I even accepted Islam so I said
if Hinduism wasn't the truth then maybe
Christianity is the truth and when I
actually looked into the Bible and
research the Bible it was kind of
confusing to me if you ever looked in
the Bible it's a very confusing thing
but I was trying to adopt the belief
that Jesus was God or the Son of God or
the Holy Spirit but in the Bible it
clearly says that God is not a man that
he should lie nor the son of man that he
should change his mind so if the Bible
says these things the Old Testament says
these things why are we why should I
believe that God has God has a son or
God is a man or God is all these things
that some Christians believe so I did
look into the multiple religions I
looked into Judaism until I found that
that you can't become a Jew you have to
be born into this and it's the same
concept with Hinduism Hindus believe
that they're so special just like the
Jews that you have to be born a Hindu
and the court and explained every
religion and detail explained
Christianity it spoke about Jesus it
spoke about Judaism it spoke about the
Hindus which are consider which were
known as the pagans and it spoke about
all the religions so the Quran in the
sense it gave me the answers for all
religions and one one thing let me ask
you this was a challenging being a new
Muslim oh yeah it was it was a great
challenge becoming a new Muslim as most
people when they learn something new
they want to share with the world and as
I said my father and my family was a
following Hindu my father actually was a
Hindu priests so when I was learning
about Islam and I learned out about the
truth of Hinduism the first thing I did
was go to my parents and say you know
mom dad did you know that this says this
did you know that you're doing something
wrong why are we worshiping these idols
why are we doing these different things
and it was it was a big shock to them
you know we grew up following the
religion of our forefathers so my
parents they took it very bad it's not
something with it was not an easy road
for me you know for the first year
becoming Muslim my parents didn't really
fully know that I was a Muslim
my mother would ask me you know why are
you growing this beard my dad would say
go shave your beard you look like a
terrorist what
you doing and it was so it was so
difficult because I had to hide to pray
my Salah I had to hide to do different
things I had to hide to go to the mud
[ __ ] I had to do I had to hide doing
everything that I that I was supposed to
do and there's nothing that I could have
said to my mother or said to my father
that would convince him otherwise I
tried everything and and every time I
would ever mention Islam to them they
would only make them angrier and angrier
and angrier so it was a definitely a
difficult journey for me amazingamazing
tell us what you know about Islam before
you became a Muslim before you submitted
to God before you start to follow Islam
would you know about it's not well
before I was a Muslim
we basically believe on what the media
tells to me of what Islam is whatever
the media says or portrays the Muslims
to be is what we were believed this is
what I believed when my friend told me
he was looking into Islam the first
thing I said to him was why are you
telling me about this terrorist religion
I remember times when I was in high
school I would pass by certain motions
and I would say you know look at these
guys plotting to do something you know
but once you start looking at Islam you
noticed that it says you shouldn't take
the life of another there's no such
thing as suicide you you can't you can't
do all these wrong things you know
whoever it takes a light innocent life
is as if you've killed all of humanity
and this is what the Quran says that one
eye in the Quran alone shows that Islam
is not what the media portrays them to
be okay for all the millions of people
who are viewing the Deen show and many
of them they need the advice is still
stuck in that trap living for the moment
so for those people living in the moment
chasing their lusts and desires what
advice do you have for them for people
that are living in the moment I was one
of those people I my motto in life was
to live every just to live my life
because time was short we never thought
about death we never thought about
what's gonna happen then we just lived
our our every fantasy and to the people
that they're right now that they might
want to be living their fantasy they
just want to do everything that pleases
them at the current moment they have to
remember that they're not promised
tomorrow none of us are if you go to any
random person accident when are you
gonna die they'll say I don't know but
we all know that death is promised to us
we're all going to die but
is this life in vain they should think
about you know is this life my advice to
the person that is living their every
fantasy and just is doing everything to
please themselves and not care about
anything else is what's the point you
have to ask yourself what's the point of
this life what is the purpose of this
life are we just here for nothing are we
just here to accumulate wealth are we
just here to just live every fantasy and
then die you know if that's a prayer is
that the purpose because then
realistically it's just no point to this
you know what's the point of just
someone being a murderer and just
killing and just that's his fantasy is
that correct in his definition killing
is what it gives him his pleasure you
know is that justice so think about the
your last moments that you don't know
when that moment will be and if you
justify that you're just having fun
you're just going to club just having
one drink that's what the murderer is
saying that's what the one who molested
the children saying they're saying I'm
just doing this because this makes me
happy this is what life is about so then
you have no right to say okay that guy
is a bad guy for killing someone because
he's doing exactly what you're doing in
a different fashion he's living out his
fantasy and he's living his pleasure
your pleasure is drinking your pleasure
is partnering partying his pleasure is
killing is he wrong by your theory think
about those things and then ask yourself
can this can just having fun and living
at your pleasure really be the purpose
of life or is this something more and
thank you so much for being with us here
on the Dean show thank you for having me
and there you have it another amazing
story here on the Dean show his father
was a Hindu priest he was a nightclub
owner and that is what surrounded his
life music entertainment and many of us
are just getting entertained and we're
not thinking about death and what comes
after death so we're getting caught up
with the live by the moment experience
how you can just go ahead and enjoy life
don't take it too seriously you're a
good person you're not hurting nobody oh
yeah really but if you go to your your
boss and you you expect to get paid but
you're not fulfilling the duties the
rights that your boss has upon you the
work obligations that he has upon you
you're the employee or now you're the
employer and
your employees are not doing the job are
you gonna pay them or can you expect to
get paid how in the end how in the world
do you expect to get paradise how in the
world do you expect to be successful
when you die on the day of judgement if
you're not living life according to how
God Almighty the Creator who created you
how he told you to live you're not even
asking you're not even asking for the
guidance asking God there's so many
people that we asked to have you asked
God to guide you everybody has some
philosophy has some ideology even if
they're not following religion they make
up a religion in their head they make up
some crazy way in their head and they
think they're gonna go ahead and pass
this along to God and say hey God you
know what go ahead and accept this with
all my funky ingredients in it no you
can't just live a life of debauchery and
live a life of hedonism and just you
know lying deceive and cheating and
doing all sorts of scandalous things and
expect to die and just say God give it
to me paradise which is eternal forever
ever know you've got to live a righteous
pious good life but let's say you've
done all those bad things but you turn
to God with a sincere heart he's the
most loved being the most merciful he
forgives all sins but you got to do it
now before death reaches you because
paradise is what we're aiming for we're
shooting from high above the stars we're
shooting for paradise that's right
that's our original home paradise that's
why our great-grandfather Adam the first
man that's where he was from that's
where we want to go back to we want to
get to paradise and we want to avoid the
Hellfire let me tell you a story before
we head out you know when when this is
not a Hadiya for nothing but we know
when when death when death talked to
life and said hey you know talked to
each other and said hey why do people
love you and hate me why don't people
love you and hate me so life looks over
at death and says hey because you're the
bitter truth and I'm a sweet lie so
don't get caught up with the lies that
are around you all their entertainment
all the reality shows and all the things
that are just wasting of your time a
waste of your time first and foremost
get around good company start asking God
to guide you and then start doing the
good that God wants you to do it's all
there we have the verbatim Word of God
and for those who would love we want to
say they want to learn more go ahead and
pick up the car at for free operators
are standing by 1 800 662 Islam if
everything made sense
today in this show and you believe that
there's only one God I should only
worship Him you believe in
accountability to that hate you know the
Hitler's of the world and all the people
who've been terrorizing people and just
getting away with it in this life that
God Almighty will bring them to account
on the day of judgement it's not that we
just died and we just disappear there's
accountability that makes sense to you
doesn't it belief in one God the day of
judgement doing good living a righteous
life this is what Islam is based on
these are just a few of the beautiful
teachings of Islam now go ahead and
learn more give us a call and don't
forget to tune in every week to the Deen
show and leave off all those bad things
live a good life doing good being good
and that's how you can truly avoid all
those enix that's how you can truly have
that peace and contentment and
satisfaction and we look forward to
having you back again with us here on
the Deen show don't forget to pick up
the new dunya to dean at this website
here at a DVD com we'll see you next
time God willing peace be with you